hello everybody and welcome to another
moneymaking guide today I'm going to be
showing you how I made 800k in 1 hour uh
from this method alone uh what we're
going to be doing is creating flighted
ogre arrows uh you'll need to do a
couple quests as well as just require
about 50 to 100K starting cache so not
much I really like it CU you get this
can be done at a very low level and uh
yeah let's jump into it so for this
moneymaking method all you're going to
need is Zer flesh eaters completed and
you will also need the Big Bird Chompy
hunting Quest done as well and where we
are is we're just a bit south of Castle
Wars right outside the jiggig uh jig
jiggig whatever and what we're going to
be doing is creating flighted arrows and
uh the reason we need Zer fles eting uh
done is because what we're going to be
doing is we're going to be buying uh the
achy logs for the flighted arrows right
from this guy's store uh so we're just
going to go like okay buy 10 buy 10 byy
10 and then you just have the knife with
you and then you're going to turn him
into the ogre shafts and then you don't
have to bank you can just do this for as
long as you want and then you're going
to attach um feathers to them to create
flighted uh ogre arrows which sell for
like 180 or something on the gr exchange
right now so pretty decent okay so yeah
we just finished the inventory
afterwards we would just attach uh some
feathers so I did some preliminary
testing before starting this video and
it seems like uh for every 5 minutes of
creating the shaft it takes about 2
minutes to um attach the arrows to them
so we're going to do about 45 minutes of
uh cutting the shafts and then we're
going to go add the arrows to them and
we'll go sell them on the grand exchange
and see how much we get it doesn't cost
very much to start doing this method
like I just started with 100K but you
probably don't even need that at all the
achy logs are only five and uh they do
sell the shop in which case you just hop
to another world it's pretty easy and uh
feathers are only like three GP so it
doesn't cost much to make it and you
actually get a pretty decent return so
if you're pretty low level or have
almost no money this is a nice way to
get a cash TX started and yeah we'll do
this for 45 minutes and then we'll hop
over to creating the arrows all right so
we did about 45 minutes of this and we
managed to get
4,745 of the ogre Arrow shafts uh now
you need four times the amount of that
in feathers to combine them cuz it uses
Four Feathers per uh shaft so uh we put
an offer and then we realized that that
there is actually a limit for the ground
exchange so be mindful and put an
offering for feathers uh maybe in
advance uh cuz this that way can
actually do it longer uh luckily we had
some feathers in the bank um but it's
pretty much simple like this you just
combine the two make 10 sets it's uh it
doesn't take that long really it
probably only take 20 minutes and that
will come back when uh they're combined
all right guys we're just finishing up
the combination for the arrows uh now we
did deposit an extra 18K into our bank
cuz cuz that is the amount of money we
would have spent on the feathers uh so
this is what we have left it costed
about uh 84k or something to do this for
another hour and we got
4,745 flighted ogre arrows uh so now
we'll go ahead and reprice check the uh
arrows flighted ogre
arrows and uh looks like we buy them for
179 uh so we'll pop these in here for uh
and uh these are going to take a little
while to sell because um there's only
20K traded a day uh but if you're
patient it will go through and uh looks
like we're selling them for
844k uh so we'll come back when they've
sold and see how much profit we actually
made all right so it did take a while
but the flighted ogre arrows did
eventually sell and we did sell them for
178 and that's going to be
844k uh so if we consider that we
started with a 100k then that is going
to leave us with about 780k in profit
almost
800k uh which is pretty nice honestly um
the main benefit to this method I'll go
for the positive and negatives uh
because there are some of both the main
positive is this can be done at a pretty
low level and with almost no starting
cash uh you do need some money for
feathers so maybe 100K would be
realistic you need to start um and it's
pretty easy to do and again not very
many requirements just need Zogo flesh
eaters and uh five Fletching or
something to make the arrows uh some of
the negatives are that um the feathers
have a buying limit so you do need quite
a few feathers and you need more than
the buying limits worth so unless you
don't do it in advance you could be
stuck waiting for the feathers and uh
the uh arrows do take a while to sell
again you will definitely sell them uh
but it could take it took me about 5
hours or something to actually sell them
all um but yeah hope you guys enjoyed
and I will see you guys in the next
video
[Music]